les sauvegardes boys et voilà on replay
ils n'ont pas demandé d'être jury en vue
du jury de the voice nom jésus serait
maintenant qu'il devrait faire ça ou pas
c'est un petit mot carax et ouais non
quoi abattant est celle où c'est chaud
luigi padovese qui soit vianney tu sais
catherine nous regardent jugé catherine
a confiance en toi tu sais catherine
connaît la réponse je peux trouver les
coordonnées catherine et lui demander
est ce que oui ou non la production de
the voice kids tu as demandé d'être
membre du jury
moi franchement je me vois pas du tout
voilà c'est pas qu'ils n'ont pas demandé
non tu te voyais voir gare de chargement
dur sur la tête de ma mère
les fourbes et il va pas tirer sur la
tête de ma mère je suis quand même
beaucoup j'adore ta maman c'est ça que
sauf que pas un truc pareil mais parce
que non c'est pas si clair que ça donc à
un délire il ya eu une guerre une
approche un petit d'elle voilà après
voilà je l'aï branché la tan ou naillon
d'attelage peux te dire non le drame on
vous retire de la faire mais ça y est tu
ne vois pas en plus que les deux sont
des conneries à noyon de lattes allait
faire un jour ils t'ont ils torito et
wap approché mais ils ont raison c'est
une très bonne idée pour the voice
kitsch aurait pris tout de suite ah
ouais alors dans le grand pâtissier ou
juste à la limite le grand ménage
[Rires]
la noria pascal obispo qui nous répond
carrière jean pascal qui nous écrit et
qui dit di achille que je l'invite
vendredi avec grand plaisir et embrasse
mon ami via n'est pas parce que je vous
dis tout le monde nous regarde
il ya jean pierre foucault aussi qui
disent comme tout cas là vous avez vu le
vieux fou qu il dit le vieux foucault
est toujours vivant 3 puis viens je vais
te péter la gueule hondelatte julie
lemieux foucault et toulon mieux on en
voit
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]